welcome to Z 0 plane yeah gentlemen
Grandmaster what is this tunisia okay a
slim [ __ ] okay this is a veteran GM
he was one of the or he was something
the first African GM if i'm not mistaken
we must be in a 60s at least okay so we
get to willow pass made nine going for
the brea again night h4 oh my yeah this
is not not particularly great but this
is all I know this kind of stuff can be
tricky okay and I t4 is the obvious move
the question is does it work mmm he also
has some 55 after that
can I can also go look Iain ok I'll do
this as with this now that said it was
tricky moves are always difficult and
blitz chess I just tried to play normal
stuff here I shoulda played G sexy
actually because he didn't have night h6
in this particular moment anyway ok c5
cannot be terribly bad and that was a
miss I should have played g6 that was a
lot stronger a lot stronger I would have
rendered the whole his whole thing it
completely useless if he has to go back
to g3 and now I'm not able to do that
anymore but ok the good thing about
those close to where positions is that
they are notoriously difficult to break
down and this is still the case here I
think
yeah it looks like a fairly normal
position wow that's usually a very bad
idea sorry but I'm going to just win
this born and I think I will I mean why
not just win the pawn it takes a long
wire but the position is so closed it is
somewhat green yeah but anyway I don't
believe this one bit here for over white
so let's go back if he takes on e5 okay
this opens up the bishop as well okay so
what is he going to do I think out
checking here and go to d6 and let's
that cannot be a bad setup i have f 5
under control and maybe night night to
h5 is something that white can do but
all in all I can even do this here right
and play Queen to h4 trying to activate
on the kingside myself I have a good PDF
go Edward pieces here for kings I play
Bishop 1c5 now he wants to go Bishop you
one after that ok I'll i have Queen to
g5 ok Quincy 593 ok that doesn't really
do much I'm I see
seven is covered so there is no
particular threat I can do this actually
tweenage for Knight takes e4 is a neat
little trick yeah I don't think he has
that on the radar oh he has no ok let's
see so he would he would take it roll
either that I understand so what I don't
want to draw of course I just wanted to
test him in a little bit ok my king
position is actually quite safe
okay and 95 or any I don't know i will i
will push here right now night there
okay this is actually quite stupid that
i did not think about the Queen comin to
g6 that I should have thought about
I was very unnecessary to even give him
this kind of ideas check time morning
48 seconds okay
now yes stuff like bishop age 6 which
probably does not work but could be
quite irritating so let's cover this
rook f8 is a good additional cover cover
move
probably should do that I know it's also
taking this time okay now it's difficult
I cannot sacrifice anymore now covering
this now let's trade this off okay does
it lead to much
yeah I want to do something myself him
his King position is actually the worst
one him mmm wow I just blundered that
porn on 85 and after that after that it
was just tried to fishing for some kind
of sacrifice it was a very strange move
away five yeah okay night h4 I know that
this move has been tried but I don't
think it's particularly great but I
don't know why I think this is an
interest this is something that I can
play but I really have no idea how it
works one thing taking is not an issue i
can take he is this is clear this was
something that I thought also it's good
for black I saw that actually but I
wasn't sure what happens if he just
plays Knight to f5 here yeah maybe I can
just go back but I mean I've only
roughly calculated this and I wasn't
sure what happens here by Queen to g3
okay so I just ignored it and this is a
mistake because I can go g6 and I didn't
take that opportunity I should have done
that after that he has to go back and
that makes the whole thing here
completely useless this kind of maneuver
I but i played this far too quickly and
now he was ready to ya to do if i play
g6 to get a check and this is obviously
not what I want ok it I think it was
still reasonably okay from
gotta we got a fairly normal position
and now yeah he can just stay let's save
their on a form um I mean don't move the
point at all but this is just I don't
understand it it just gives away the
pawn I don't think that white has
compensation for that the position is
too closed and to too slow in nature to
justify that pawn sacrifice and he
actually I get a very very nice piece
position yeah it was a little trick and
you never know okay Queen jf three Jim I
think this is probably winning for black
he only has those tries for sacrifices
but I I did not play well now
prophylactically absolutely not okay I
wanted to speed up there and play before
quite quite quickly but I should
anticipate this move and play some look
at eight for example and this is this is
just stronger to allow me to cover this
conveniently and after this it's
slightly annoying i have to have to do
something that I don't want to do and
actually went is this and now here at
the engine still says I'm I'm clearly
better more less winning but it feels a
bit uncomfortable that allowed Queen to
g6 pin it's still all like minus minus
one point something for the common you
know the Queen site is decisive
try to trade that yeah I didn't want to
defend passively they're all whole time
the thing is he has bishop is dad there
won't be one so I just have to make sure
that i'm not getting checkmated that's
the only way to lose here to blunder
into a maid no idea why this zoom smarty
cannot cannot do anything united for
it's a strange line but ok it seemed
that even normal play is kind of okay
against it ok well thanks for watching